i am on a zoom conference call right now
and uh
to step away from the girls just so i
can pick up this call
but they are not letting me have it
they're screaming all day
we are t and adam and we have
eight-month-old twins rev and skye and
this week we are going to show you how
we work full-time in parent good morning
oh somebody just
threw up on me like literally this is
huge i'm gonna give them a bath
daddy's still asleep so managing working
from home day to day with the girls here
with us
is challenging but we've kind of worked
out a good system so like we break the
day up into shifts
so that we can at least have solid
blocks of time that are uninterrupted
normally we don't have to go in at work
but this week we both have to go in and
us both having to go in in the same week
is a lot today
doing double duty for work i am an
attorney i work for the government and
i'm also the music director at uh
progressive church i am a property
manager i am a real estate broker
um i am pretty much all over the place i
literally have about four jobs my jobs
are really demanding and it's one of
those 24-hour jobs yeah my jobs are
demanding fortunately they're flexible
so uh even though i'm an attorney i'm
able to work from home the girls have
gone down for their first nap they
should sleep for about an hour and a
half which means i get an hour and a
half block of time to try to get my own
work done so when it comes to paternity
leave i only got two weeks from my job
paid leave i
honestly got one week of parent to leave
and it seems like another issue with
parental leave especially as like gay
dads is that a lot of these companies
make their policies based on this
heteronormative idea of a family where
there's a man and a woman we have two
men who are married which is a pretty
common thing but it definitely does not
work for most families
so today i will be going into the office
in a few minutes i'm still at home right
now as you can hear the kids are going
crazy this morning
the big challenge is trying to work
while you're watching the kids is
when they start doing this
that's
just really tricky that's where you get
interrupted that's why we divide the day
in half so i'm going down right now um
to say bye to kids
let's see how this goes
i have a good day
i just feel bad for adam
but also i'm gonna miss him knowing that
he had to go in i like tried to be as
prepared as possible so really making
sure the bottle situation is locked down
diapers are stocked wipes are good to go
like all of it just having everything in
order so i have been doing my property
inspection today
it's almost like two o'clock
and i'm still working on this property
inspection i wonder how adam is doing
there
as a property manager basically this is
what i do i drive to all these
properties i basically
check on the properties making sure
everything is good there is no repairs
that needs to be done it felt good to be
out of the house
it was refreshing
just the drive
yeah i mean i missed the kitchen i
missed the kids i was quite worried
about adam the whole time but
i missed the kids but it was really good
going through teething we're going
through separation anxiety usually when
it gets to this point i will sit on the
floor with them i will have my laptop
handy
and
i think just like being close to them
satisfies them enough that they feel
comfortable playing on their own
and i can just sit here on the phone
get some work done bad news
the baby monitor just went off
after 38 minutes the girls are already
awake this was supposed to be an hour
and a half nap so i am losing about an
hour of
work time it's almost as though they
know
that i'm home alone
and
i already have a lot going on because
skye just had
a blowout a blowout a blowout a blowout
so
removing bath time up a few hours
i'm gonna go get them cleaned off
and see if uh see if there's gonna be
any time left in the day to do any work
at all we've now had
blow out we've had waking up from our
nap an hour early
we've had a mood it's been a morning so
this is one that happens all the time
i'm working and then rev comes up and
starts banging on the keyboard deletes
my appointments sends emails to people
that i wasn't trying to send emails to
it's amazing the things that they're
able to do
without really knowing what they're
doing it's getting a little late so i'm
probably gonna head home soon
hello
hi
how was your day
that's a long one i walked in the house
and the house was like so clean and
perfect
like but you said you had a crazy day so
i'm like huh i can't tell good job
thanks so much
after hours work session
my children decided that they needed to
be filled up with
their
stuff so working late it's always the
plans that get disrupted that are the
hardest for me yep it's just not how i
roll it is six o'clock in the morning i
decided to get up and work out early
because adam will be gone the whole day
today and i will be having the kids the
whole day so my plan is to kind of start
out early
so if i can get my workout out
take a shower and the kids should be up
at seven and that's if i'm lucky even
though i will be working from home it
could be quite difficult
when you have two kids that you are
taking care of when calls come in it's
really really hard
to have a conversation if the kids are
crying you see how it goes you know it
is 6 50 the kids are still sleeping this
is great
so i'm gonna stop prepping right now and
the kids are up i'm gonna
run down and get a bottle for them
and let the day begin
leaving for the day i felt less guilty
about leaving tea behind if i'm being
honest and a little more guilty about
just like leaving the girls behind
because it was it's something that we
don't really ever do and so being away
from them for that period of time kind
of
tugged at my heart love you
have a good day
skye be good it's kind of
weird leaving
the girls at home but it's also nice to
be able to like go to a place where
there are no interruptions and you can
just kind of work straight through it
also makes me sort of feel like a real
person again to be
leaving the house and out in the world
so i couldn't do any of my calls but i
was able to do some emails but like
calls and conference calls those were
extremely tough just
just
unless you are holding her
now she stopped
the kids finally went to bed for a nap
probably they would be sleeping for
another hour and a half this guy's
only slept for an hour not even an hour
oh my god
so i'm gonna have to go get there i feel
bad for people who actually have to do
this every day luckily i have adam so
this doesn't happen every day where i am
not able to jump on meetings or have a
call without no one helping me but just
imagine someone having their kids the
whole time 24 7. like you basically
won't be able to do anything at all i
can barely get any work done really skye
is
running her mouth just screaming um
and i can't even like do any calls skye
is not having it it's like i have to
sleep and come down here and just play
with them
this is how i'm getting any work done at
this moment and i did not know that we
scheduled
like some workers out here which i need
to supervise as well so now i'm
supervising kids supervising workers
supervising
my job just all of it yeah this is my
day
it was a lot
nothing have went according to schedule
today nothing at all the kids fussing
just craziness but
i just put them back
to bed for their last nap for the day
i am praying again that this time they
will sleep for an hour and a half i am
trying to make dinner
and i cannot because they want me to
hold them the whole time
my chaos
yes
so good to be home
get to see my babies hello
hello hello hello
just chill with them all day
looks like a pretty good setup i'm not
saying it was like the most stressful
day but it was a day with a lot going on
i one time forgot to eat can you believe
i forgot to eat like i just realized i'm
like oh my god i haven't hate and you
never forget to eat yeah it is not easy
to work and parent full time and i am
happy we have each other yeah so you
have someone to share the blowouts with
exactly
[Music]
you